prosecutors at the Alex Murdoch murder
trial have won the right to use
important evidence against the disgraced
lawyer who was accused of killing his
wife and his son the judge ruled
yesterday that the jury will be allowed
to hear evidence that Murdoch committed
Financial crimes prosecutors claim those
alleged actions point to a motive for
murder Murdoch denies killing anyone our
Nikki Batiste is in South Carolina
covering the trial Nikki good morning
David good morning two weeks after this
trial began the judge's ruling marks a
potential breakthrough for the
prosecution they say Alex Murdoch was
stealing money from his law firm and
clients and claimed he killed his wife
and son to gain sympathy before his
alleged fraud came to light
this evidence of other crimes is
admissible prosecutors argue a driving
Factor behind Alex Murdoch's alleged
actions on Monday judge Clifton Newman
ruled testimony about it was fair game
this evidence furnishes a part of the
context
of the alleged crime
is necessary to the full presentation of
the case prosecutors say Murdoch's
alleged motive stemmed in part from a
2019 incident involving his son Paul who
was charged with driving Under the
Influence after a boat he was allegedly
operating crashed leading to the death
of 19-year-old Mallory Beach a hearing
in the boat crash civil case which
prosecutors claim would have included
Financial records revealing years of
fraud had been set for three days after
Alex Murdoch's wife and son were killed
Mark Tinsley is a lawyer for the beach
family he testified that if Murdoch had
been a grieving victim in his family's
murders nobody would have brought a
verdict back against Alec I would have
ended the case against Allen in police
footage from the night of the murders
Murdoch told investigators about his
son's legal woes in what he called
negative publicity surrounding the boat
crash he's been punched and hit and just
attacked a lot
so you know but I mean nothing like this
now the jury in Murdoch's murder trial
will hear testimony from Witnesses about
millions of dollars he allegedly stole
from a variety of victims including
clients and his housekeepers family she
died in an accident on Murdoch's
property in 2018. in another pivotal
moment Monday a caregiver for Murdoch's
ill mother took the stand and appeared
to cast doubt on Murdoch's Alibi
regarding the length of time he visited
his mother the night of the murders she
said Murdoch had spoken to her days
later explicitly telling her he'd been
at his mother's for 30 to 40 minutes how
long did he stay there
20 minutes about 20 minutes
that witness whose name is Shelly Smith
said she was so bothered by her
conversation with Murdoch that she
called her brother a police officer to
ask what she should do up next we expect
to hear from a law enforcement expert
today who will testify about evidence of
gunshot residue found the night of the
murders David
Nikki Batiste in South Carolina thank
you Nikki